thanks guys uh alireza first of all
congratulations what an important uh
Victory you took down the world champion
you took down the Challenger as well how
are you feeling right now yeah it feels
great
has a very solid reporter with black so
it's really difficult to
get the game even against him so I'm
really happy with this win and this
improves my stun my score in the
standings that was in fact my next
question I said at the beginning of the
show that is going to be very difficult
to take him out of his opening
preparation but you definitely showed
your intent to do just that early on
with this like D4 Knight F3 E3 the coal
system uh very cagey stuff Bishop P2
it's reversed Queen's Indian and
it's a
it's not anything special but it's
interesting to get a game at least I was
happy
um of course black is okay around here
and
and he also seems to be playing quite
some challenging lines Bishop G4 like he
doesn't shy away from yeah it's not easy
it's the most concrete yeah there is no
concrete line maybe there's so he played
the best line actually and Bishop G4 is
the best move probably yeah and yeah and
probably he missed hope he should have
played better around here maybe instead
of Bishop C5 I prefer A5 for instance
yeah to prevent and then each stop takes
is very very equal but
um yeah of course he played like this
and I think I have age here I was maybe
he was thinking about picture she was
losing probably
first I was afraid of this but I have P5
here very important
is B5 the only move we didn't even
consider it yeah it's kind of funny move
yeah yeah that makes sense yeah because
B5 and then B6 checkp takes his son with
a bit of a new Queen there yeah son he
didn't have this tactic and but he
played amazing greatly here I think
yeah my knight C4 probably is not
accurate but I wanted to go directly
here yeah to see what happens
and yeah he played Bishop B2 Knight G5
yeah here Knight G5 was amazing move I
missed it very well yeah because I
blundered in my calculation these
King G2 Bishop G4 Knight D6 I was
calculating Rook D6 B5
but
yeah I missed this Knight E4
and if you take with the picture 54 he
takes takes check and E5
oh that's nice that's the only way that
he can I think he has another way to
make drawing instead of 94. that's a
nice line yeah yeah beautiful
um but yeah it was interesting 95 and
yeah I had to go for Knight D6 and this
position is probably equal
but he has to be still a bit careful I
think because he loses opponents is upon
he doesn't have any other way 95 queen
of four I'm better
so in fact I think the critical line
here was Knight to G6
E7 Queen C5
why is the night better on G6 than on F5
ah because it defends the last rank you
could give a shake
and takes it so now you cannot do this
because Knight of Faith yeah black is
winning oh okay that's such a small deal
yeah yeah oh yeah now I don't have Queen
C5 so I mean I have Queen C5 for this
probably just throw
King H2
coinage for it's still very complicated
this is some crazy life yeah
um computer light yeah yeah no it's very
it's not easy here for black actually
because he's down opponent he has to
prove he's well if not G6 is the only
way out yeah practically is almost
impossible yeah but he played good here
actually for yeah I didn't understand
what you're looking at
um Knight H4 I was planning Queen C4
oh yeah of course yeah for a human to go
deep voice inside
because I calculated this 92.4 and I'm
probably winning here Bishop B6 so
important
and it wins yeah
um
but
so yeah he played okay yeah if you don't
see G5 then you have to go okay you guys
discussed a little bit at the end of the
game yeah it was for the ink I didn't
understand so much what he said but it
was about the Ingham I think that's your
game yes you can go there yeah here I
think I should go Bishop C3 is easier to
win it was stupid I commended this move
Bishop to A1 just for the simple fact
that this end game is actually
mathematically anything yeah I am I felt
like it has to be winning
because you get the pawn to H5 first
it's I think
it's even this is this is even winning
probably
like I'm sure this is winning no
um for H5
um because I still could go he cannot go
look at five I take
so this should be losing anything else
you have some sacrifices at some point
yeah this could be losing as well and
also you cannot get his King to G7 so
it's important for instance if he gets
these movies
still probably losing
yes it's not easy and his thought is
probably draw here but yeah it was easy
after it was born on H5 and
yeah I could have always go to pawning
game and yeah yeah it was actually I
think it's it's it might be a draw if
these two pawns the hng uh pawns are
swapped for the F2 Pawn that's true and
then you have Rook H6 extra Square he
was hoping for this like after Rook A3
he was hoping for Queen C6 I think
and
to take your pie yeah this is winning
but for instance
because he cannot get his Rook to E6 but
I'm sure this is true
yes this is true I think yeah yes yeah
this is the best yeah which is quite
funny
uh big sequence of important games for
you and you got the maximum out of every
single one of them even yesterday
against Fabiano uh congratulations going
into the championship rounds as a
co-leader what are your Ambitions right
now what do you think you need to do to
win the tournament yeah um for sure
Fabiano is also in very good shape and
it's not easy to
move
outrank him didn't turn on but I will
try to play good I have tomorrow black
pieces with doodle and we will see what
happens
um he's really great fighter and we'll
see thank you very much for joining us
we'll see you tomorrow